foreign
shocking news a popular blogger Madison
with 2 million subscribers has been
kidnapped in Thailand it all happened
when she accidentally met a girl from
the same Hotel the next day her
documents were stolen and after a couple
more she herself disappeared it turns
out that a seemingly sweet friend is a
Serial Maniac who kidnapped blogger
girls to run accounts instead of them
and get paid for it
she took Madison to a desert island and
took over her account but the worst
thing is that no one noticed the loss of
the famous blogger stay tuned as we
uncover the shocking details of this
gripping case
Jill this is just the plot of the movie
but do you really think it's impossible
to pull this off
this video was created by some sub the
verification platform we keep cyber
criminals out of your wallet but more
about us in a bit
the main idea of this movie isn't new
the term identity theft first appeared
in 1964 and referred to fraud in which
the perpetrator used the documents or
credentials of another person to commit
an offense in this way it was possible
to forge a check or gain illegal access
to the victim's bank account in the U.S
stealing a social security number allows
an intruder to get medical care that
will be paid from the victim's Insurance
account later identity theft was used by
telephone freaks to illegally access
telephone networks and switchboards to
make free calls in hooliganism with the
Advent of computer networks many freaks
began using the same technology to gain
unauthorized access to them for example
they could call a company's computer
center get a system administrator on the
phone pretend to be a digital Equipment
Corporation or IBM support staff and
tell them that the dangerous
vulnerability had been discovered in the
company's software the vulnerability can
be fixed without shutting down the
computers but the system administrator
should Grant the caller privileged
access to the company's Network one of
the most famous hackers perfectly able
to pretend to be another identity and
gain the trust of victims was Kevin
mitnick not a hacker for profit like we
see today but more a hacker for
intellectual curiosity he was not averse
to rummaging through rubbish dumps near
the offices of large companies in search
of discarded documents containing names
personal details phone numbers and job
titles of employees it helped him
defraud the security services of
California's largest companies but it
also landed him in the dock for the
first time at the age of 17. mitnik went
to prison several times but gave up
hacking to become a world-renowned
information security expert he is
lectured around the world and written
several best-selling books with a heavy
heart we bid farewell to the fascinating
Kevin mitnick who left us on July the
16th 2023 aged 59. his spirit will
forever be remembered and cherished
in the movie an antagonist named CW used
information from the internet to track
down her victims is that really possible
absolutely yes today there is no need
for hackers and fraudsters to rummage
around rubbish bins they have a giant
dumpster at their disposal called the
internet we leave a huge number of
digital footprints on the internet when
we register with different websites
social networks also collect information
about us there are regular data leaks
and personal information can become
publicly available every time we sign up
for online services or just browse the
web we leave a huge digital footprint
there are a number of ocean services
that can help to gather this data yes
anonymity is a luxury these days anyone
can become a detective
shut up let's simply run an experiment
open Google in your browser and type
your name there adding the string site
colonfacebook.com you'll get a link to
your profile on Facebook if it exists
and links to all mentions of you on that
social network if there are any people
with that name you can add a city to the
query like this this way fraudsters can
find basic information about you on the
internet open your Facebook profile in
an incognito or private window to see
what information your Facebook is making
public to the world at a minimum you can
find out the age place of employment
education details now repeat the search
for Instagram Twitter and Linkedin
you'll collect a lot of information
about yourself right when you post your
photos on the web you should know that
they contain service metadata this
collects information about when the
photo was taken what device it was taken
with and the geographical coordinates of
where it was taken Facebook Twitter and
Instagram automatically remove metadata
from photos but Flickr and Tumblr do not
fraudsters can extract information from
your photos if it's available this this
is how hackers can calculate the
location of your home within a foot if
there is a recognizable place in the
photo a Google photo search will show
where the photo was taken finding out
your email address and phone number is
not that difficult if the place of
employment is known if you leave your
email address on websites it can be
found on the internet using Google or
ocean Services if not this is where
social engineering comes to the aid of
attackers scammers may call your
company's contact number found on the
corporate website and ask how to get in
touch with you also they may send you a
message in social media with a link to a
fake authorization form where you enter
your email or phone number they may then
call you after knowing some of the
details imagine receiving the call
hello is this Mr John Smith
congratulations you have won a 40
discount in Walmart in lower Brooklyn
where you usually shop could you please
confirm your date of birth and your
postal address to ensure that we call
John Smith right it is such a common
name you know if you want to know how
much information from social media can
leak without your knowledge Watch the
documentary The Great hack by Netflix
indeed it's never been easier to forge
documents or recreate someone's identity
through the darknet and face app
programs are only getting more and more
sophisticated by the day hi this is
Lucas from sumsup and I'm here to tell
you about how we at some sub fight
criminals and ensure authenticity of
legitimate customers this can be done by
implementing some sub simple face
authentication check also known as
liveness some subs in-house liveness
technology can detect masks photoshopped
images or deep fakes using our own
comprehensive AI solution this software
uses a people-friendly facial biometric
approach that works equally well across
the globe it takes just two to four
seconds to authenticate users resulting
in Pass rates as high as 99 liveness can
be used in various forms from detecting
duplicate accounts to enhance due
diligence checks on suspicious user
activity for more information on how to
implement liveness follow the link in
the description below
well imagine an intruder got a lot of
information about you in the film
influencer The Villain blogged on social
media on behalf of her victim is that
possible in the real world unfortunately
a positive answer again an attacker
doesn't have to steal your smartphone if
they get hold of your email address and
password using social engineering
methods they will change your password
on social networks and compose as you if
a hacker gains access to your email
account and you don't have two-factor
authentication set up he can gain access
to Messengers there are a large number
of applications that allow you to change
the face in photos we listed them in a
previous video using these apps the
fraudster can post your new photos on
social media for a long time even if
you've long been maroon on a desert
island with no communication the villain
in the film used voice altering software
to communicate with the victim's lover
such programs exist in reality too they
are often used by pranksters to call
someone in President Biden's voice back
in 2017 the Canadian startup lyrebird
announced the world's first service with
which you can fake the voice of any
person a minute sample is enough to
train the system the demo posted on
Soundcloud shows some phrases spoken by
the voice of Donald Trump there are many
applications that allow you to change
your voice in real time for example
while talking on the phone but most of
these applications only allow you to
change the Timbre pitch and other
characteristics of the voice to copy the
voice of a real person you need voice
samples and it's easier to do this with
recorded voice messages but there are
also apps that can copy your voice from
a short sample and play it back in real
time such as real-time voice cloning so
if the villain has a sample of your
voice we have very bad news for you what
about the video with the victim that's
not a problem either with deep fake
technology the most popular free
instrument is deep face lap and we have
already talked about it however to
create a high quality deep fake the
neural network needs to be trained on a
set of your photos if you don't publish
a lot of your photos on the web don't
worry deep fakes can also be
distinguished from real videos by
watching them in slow motion or frame by
frame it will show the truth how to spot
and deep fake pay attention to the edges
of the head especially the hair ears and
tip of the nose neural networks are not
yet very good at processing those areas
and you may see artifacts such as dark
spots different details in the areas of
the face and Distortion of Contours
get how the person in the video blinks
blinking in deep fakes often looks
unnatural sometimes deep fakes have
different colored eyes neural networks
are bad dentists deep fake's teeth are
often not drawn in detail and look like
white stripes unnatural facial
expressions can be a sign of deep fake
the fraudster may use a person of
similar build and height but you should
still look out for peculiarities of the
figure and distinctive features of the
real person tattoos moles and scars
remember that neural networks are
constantly evolving and the quality of
deep fakes is improving how about
stealing the victim's money if
fraudsters get hold of your cell phone
or SIM card and they know your bank card
details nothing will protect you from
theft to keep yourself safe Disable face
ID when opening banking apps they should
only open with a password or two-factor
authentication also set a pin code lock
on your sim card to protect yourself if
your phone is lost or stolen and
fraudsters try to install the SIM card
in another phone to get the verification
SMS and block your bank cards
immediately if a pretty girl suggests
you visit a deserted island but even if
you do all of this there is nothing to
stop scammers from contacting your
social media friends on your behalf and
asking for money
[Music]
with access to your social networks
information about you your photos voice
and video the criminal can become you
but why in the film The Villain s was a
maniac she killed victims out of hatred
but what about in reality there are
several motives for identity theft the
first is of course financial fraud this
category includes obtaining bank card
details to withdraw money and make
purchases and producing false documents
to obtain loans there have been cases of
hacking social media profiles or
creating clones and sending them
messages to friends on behalf of the
victim asking them to send money to
fraudsters according to the Texas
Attorney General's website crimes like
this happen regularly so Carlos from San
Antonio said that his personal
information was used by an ID Thief to
buy a sports car open four credit card
accounts each with ten thousand dollar
lines of credit open and spend about two
thousand dollars on a Walmart credit
card account and rent an apartment
fraudsters like the high life the second
one is committing illegal acts on behalf
of another person which can get the
victim in trouble with the law this can
be either out of Revenge or to hide the
fraudster's real identity Malcolm bird
was arrested in 2003 on a warrant for
possession of cocaine although his name
was eventually cleared Byrd learned that
a criminal had used his name when he was
arrested he spent some time in jail
before being released the third reason
is used by people fleeing from creditors
or other types of persecutors illegal
immigrants a stolen identity will help
them hide away in his book ghost in the
wires Kevin mitnick recalled repeatedly
using data he had stolen from real
people to obtain documents for himself
in their names this helped him hide from
the FBI the FBI was actually at my
apartment medical identity theft is used
by criminals mainly to purchase
prescription-only drugs such as
narcotics finally clone creation often
fraudsters create fake pages of actors
musicians or athletes on social networks
to use a well known name for illegal
purposes for example to advertise
pyramid schemes online casinos or other
dubious projects or just for fun as you
can see attackers usually have purely
commercial motives for identity theft
nevertheless anyone can become a victim
of a Maniac keep this in mind if a
pretty girl offers you a romantic trip
to an uninhabited Island while on
vacation in Thailand take care of
yourself
foreign